and I know what you're both capable of
For Better or Worse what are they
capable of
[Music]
[Applause]
the two of us we are the closest living
out here Ellie and me
[Music]
it's all right you're with me take it
slow the drugs are still wearing off hey
is this real life
yes
one
eternity later
[Applause]
it's pretty dead
yeah you need to come into the office
right now
did I know but
a vaccine
bomb them bomb them keep bombing them
bomb them again
I got something to show you you mean a
penis not that
I'm not interested in caring about
people there's a sign at rampsit Park
that says do not drink the sprinkler
water so I made sun tea with it and now
I have an infection
come on
I'm guessing you found this Joel because
anyone else would have been electrocuted
or blown up by one of my traps vaginas
you live in a psycho bunker where 911
was an inside job and and the government
are all Nazis the government are
minorities
why are all these Pages stuck together
uh
I am your cool [__] Daddy
look girl you've been running wild on me
for a [__] week
Carol
I consider that [__] to be one of the
biggest terrorists in the exotic animal
world right now
[Applause]
thank you I ain't telling you [__]
it's okay I believe him no
don't stop doing full force
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true I swear
why you always lying
hi there is there a project you're
working on I know more than you
that's it girls okay here we go
virtual change thank you
yeah we're cool
everybody loved contractors you don't
want to paint with a broad brush here
but every single contractor in the world
is a miserable incompetent Thief
you got any advice on the best way west
yeah
go east
[Music]
ER
it's Jimmy's Place
Ellie come on
oh
hi
I'm a giraffe
free double kill triple kill over a kill
killionaire kill him and
can you name the truck with four-wheel
drive smells like a stink and seats 35.
[Music]
um how does a computer get drunk
it takes screenshots
what are screenshots I don't actually
know
can I have a gun absolutely not okay
geez it's fine I'll just throw a [__]
sandwich at them
would you like me to shake your luggage
yes ma'am right away man I'm a weird kid
[Music]
[Applause]
look what the homosexuals have done to
me
die
die then every bum you talk to about it
is going to show up here looking for a
free lunch
and this is not an Arby's I'm
[Music]
for what it's worth there's room for you
in our group if you want
you're inviting me to your hunger Club
imagine the life we could build once you
have a seat there and get comfortable
for that
it's a good friend she's not my
girlfriend
damn
us
well kids die Henry they die all the
time you crazy evil [__] this is the
commune we're Communists
I didn't like that
[Laughter]
what did I do have you forgotten you
killed your brother
[Music]
hi welcome to Chili's
we got a lot of extra here you know
y'all want some biscuits
you ready
to smash the buttons there's so many of
them
ow use the joystick okay
I've ever seen in my life
laughs
I have an extremely high libido is that
too much saying I have an extremely high
libido should I just said a high level
okay
Joe shut up
good people who have traveled from
Villages near and far lend me your ear
oh
she would have liked you she had a
killer smile lovely now your [__] has
pretty much ruined my week and I'd like
to go home and drink till my face stops
hurting
[Music]
no no no sir no thank you sorry not this
song not this song
[Music]
oh
foreign
Frank
we will never have friends
[Laughter]
no no no no it's okay it's okay it's
over we're not fighting anymore
[Music]
what is a mermaid where did her math
class
an ouchy bra
it up all night no
what the [__] is that
you talking to me
you got it pretty early if you want to
grab more sleep I'm not even tired
[Music]
so we're [__] tall man that's just
the way he sounds he has an [__]
voice Joe tell him he's okay everything
is great dude
[Applause]
[Music]
endure survive yeah man
[Applause]
I gotta tell you
perfect everything down to the last
minute details hey guys if you like this
video and want to see more content like
this make sure to like subscribe and
leave a comment below on what your
favorite meme was until next time Daddy
loves you very much
foreign